it does seem if you sort of reason
basically that there should be a lot of
alien civilizations out there if the
human species
if earth is not that unique
by
basic
no matter the values you pick
it's likely that there's a lot of alien
civilizations out there and if that's
the case
why have they
not at least obviously visited us or
sent us loud signals that everybody can
hear
fermi is quoted as saying sitting down
at lunch i think it was with
teller
and
herb york who was kind of the one of the
fathers of the atomic bomb
and he sat down and he says something
like where are they
which meant where are these
other and
um
and then he did some
numerology where he
calculated you know how many what they
knew about how many
uh
galaxies there are and how many stars
and how many planets then are like the
earth and blah blah blah that's been
done much better by somebody named drake
uh and so people usually refer to the i
don't know whether it's called the drake
formula or something but it has the same
conclusion
the conclusion is it would be a miracle
if there weren't other you know uh
there's the statistics are so high that
how can we be singular and separate
that so probably there is
well there's
almost certainly life somewhere maybe
there was even life on mars a while back
but
uh
intelligent life
probably white or we so so you know the
statistics say that communicating with
us
i think that it's harder than people
think
uh
we might
not know the right way to
expect the communication
but
all the communication that we know about
travels at the speed of light
and we do we don't we don't think
anything can go faster in the speed of
light that
limits the problem quite quite a bit and
it uh
makes it difficult to have any back and
forth communication you can send signals
like we try to or
look for but to have any communication
it's pretty hard when you it has to be
close enough that the speed of light
would mean we could communicate with
each other and i think
and we didn't even understand that i
mean it was an advanced civilization but
we didn't even understand that
a little more than 100 years ago
so
are we
just not advanced enough maybe
to know something about that's the speed
of light maybe there's some other way to
communicate that isn't based on
electromagnetism i don't i don't know
gravity seems to be also this have the
same speed that was a principle that
einstein had and something we've
measured actually
so is is it possible i mean so we'll
talk about gravitational waves and
it in some sense there's um
there's a brainstorming going on which
is like
how do we detect the signal like what
would a signal look like and how would
we detect and that's true for
gravitational waves that's true for
basically any physics phenomena
you have to predict that that signal
should exist you have to have some kind
of theory and model why that signal
should exist
i mean is it possible that aliens are
communicating with us via gravity
like why not
well it it
yeah it's true why not
for us it's very hard to detect these
gravitational effects they have to come
from something
pretty that has a lot of gravity like
black holes
but we're pretty primitive
at this stage uh
there's uh
very reputable physicists that look for
a fifth force
one that we haven't found yet maybe it's
the key so you know
it's what would that look like what
would a fifth force of physics look like
exactly well usually they think it's
probably a long range for longer range
force than we have now
but
they're reputable for colleagues of mine
that spend their life looking for a
fifth force so longer range than gravity
yeah
super it doesn't fall off like one over
r squared but maybe
separately
gravity
uh newton taught us goes like inversely
one over the square of the distance
apart you are so it falls pretty fast
that's okay so now we have a theory of
what consciousness is it's just the
fifth force of
physics yeah there we go that's a good
hypothesis
you